so exciting to talk to you guys about
season five this show has just like has
taken off griffin i want to ask you
first of all you know here at canada
there are a lot of families that are
fans of cobra kai like generational
karate kid cobra kai fans
if people run into you on the street
that are fans of the show who gets more
excited the kids are the parents
oh that's really i never thought uh i
would say that i've gotten mostly
younger people coming up to me
but
i think the
older people i've met have always been
more like dude you know you're the boy
like i love i love the original movies
you know i think they have such a
longer connection to the franchise but i
think in general i end up getting
younger kids very cool
now you know
where we left off in season four is an
interesting spot always great
cliffhangers with the show cobra kai
stronger than ever dallas una is it a
good time
to be
in cobra kai
um i i think is it is the perfect time
to be in cobra kai right now
cobra kai is taking over the valley i
think it is just a great moment a great
opportunity to be in the best dojo
around
yes i think they get to learn a lot from
all the senseis that come in and
it really is the prime time to be in
cobra kai
always this really great push and pull
of like
light and dark in this series like good
and bad and trying to figure out where
you stand it kind of like mirrors and
reflects what it's like growing up
anyways
uh
what do you guys love about being able
to play those characters and play all
those sides to them
especially now as we're we're seeing
where cobra kai is in this season
right i love that all the characters
are so flawed because i think it makes
them more relatable too and um there
isn't like a clear-cut good versus evil
so much you know everyone's kind of in
that gray area
mm-hmm
dallas yeah i guess if you take anyone
that's not oh
no i was gonna say i think if you take
anyone who's not a sensei it's kind of
hard to put them in the category of good
or evil everyone's just kind of doing
what they think is right at the time
yeah yeah
um we are always treated to really great
big fight scenes in this show every
season without giving anything away and
i think it's safe to say we'll get a
good one this season too who gets the
most hype
about doing those big fight sequences
ooh
out of the three of us right yeah
oh
well anyone out of anyone actually i
love doing the fights they're my
favorite part honestly yeah yeah
i'm gonna actually have to go with luna
i feel like every single time she has a
fight sequence she's really hyping
herself up and i i love that i love i
love that energy it's very exuberant so
i'm gonna have to go with luna oh yeah
we get really loud we often play games
to see like who can scream the loudest
in fights
so a lot of a lot of the sound effects
we're just like
as loud as we can yeah you get very
hyped
so when fans are watching that back
that's what they have to look out for
like who won
the loudest ki competition yes oh for
sure
exactly yeah winner gets ice that's the
real battle for sure
well guys i want to say congratulations
on the season thank you so much for
taking the time uh we'll see you soon
next time thank you
you